bonjour manuel bompard à merci de
répondre à nos questions en direct sur
arte france selon vous l'activité
d'airbus est un secteur non essentiels
par conséquent par conséquent vous
estimez que cette reprise partielle
mettant en danger les travailleurs
pourquoi est-ce que ce secteur n'est pas
essentiel à vos yeux des livraisons de
masques de protection arrive portant par
avion là je pense qu'il faut distinguer
ce qui peut y avoir dans l'activité
d'airbus et qui est une activité
essentielle à permettre à la société de
continuer à vivre en ce moment et ce qui
ne l'est pas en l'occurrence il peut y
avoir des tâches par exemple de
maintenance puisque certain nombre de
compagnies aériennes ont continué à
avoir un nombre réduit de vol mais des
tâches de production les chaînes
d'assemblage des nouveaux avions
ça me paraît pas effectivement
indispensable dans le moment actuel à la
fois d'exposer les salariés parce que
bien sûr il ya des conditions de
sécurité qui sont mis en place mais
c'est bien des gens qui se déplacent
pour aller sur leur lieu de travail et à
la fois de protéger la société parce que
si des salariés sont contaminés ou se
contaminent les uns les autres c'est la
lutte globale contre l'épidémie qui se
revoient qui se voit handicapé il faut
dire aussi que quand airbus se remet en
route
peut-être que l'entreprise airbus elle
même a les moyens de mettre en place un
certain nombre de conditions de sécurité
mais elle réactive toute une chaîne de
sous traitants kg n'ont pas forcément
les mêmes moyens et donc c'est pas
seulement les salariés d'airbus qui
retournent au travail c'est aussi toute
la chaîne de sous traitance et ça à mon
avis ça fait peser un risque qui n'est
pas raisonnable sur la bataille que nous
menons aujourd'hui contre la propagation
de ce virus est l'un des arguments du
groupe airbus c'est l'enjeu économique
avec la préservation des emplois vous
parlez de sous traitants notamment à
préserver donc ces emplois est ce que
c'est un argument suffisant à vos yeux
et si non pourquoi
c'est un argument qu'il faut bien sûr
entendre tout le monde souhaite
préserver ses emplois
mais c'est pas un argument l'argument
économique qui doit primer sur celui de
la vie des salariés et notamment des
salariés d'airbus et de et de ses
sous-traitants il ya un certain nombre
de dispositifs gouvernementaux qui ont
été mis en place pour faire en sorte que
les entreprises qui verraient leurs
activités économiques pénalisé dans la
période obtiennent des compensations
nécessaires il faut que
ces dispositifs soient accessibles à
airbus et à ses sous traitants mais de
mon point de vue je pense qu'il n'est
pas raisonnable de relancer les chaînes
d'assemblage et les chaînes de
production il faut rajouter un argument
c'est que vous avez dit tout à l'heure
mais les salariés d'airbus bénéficient
de matériel de protection certes mais le
matériel de prenez protection dont ils
bénéficient ceux qui n'en bénéficient
pas ce sont nos soignants qui sont et
qui eux dénoncent des mangues ce sont
les personnels de santé ce sont celles
et ceux qui sont dans des secteurs qui
peut sont indispensables même en temps
de crise à l'économie donc voilà je
pense qu'il faut être un peu plus
cohérent le gouvernement parce qu'il a
une responsabilité dans cette situation
multiplie les injonctions qui sont
contradictoires entre d'un côté des
mesures de confinement et en même temps
des propos type il faut aller travailler
il faut venir aider les agriculteurs
dans les chambres et donc les gens ne
comprennent plus après ça laisse la
possibilité aux chefs d'entreprises de
prendre des décisions de manière
unilatérale je pense que c'est pas
raisonnable
emmanuel macron s'est exprimé à la mi
journée il a annoncé notamment une
hausse de la production pour des masques
de protection
il a qualifié également d' irresponsable
je cite ceux qui cherchent un déjà à
faire des procès votre réaction
mais je pense que personne en tout cas
la france insoumise ne souhaite ne n'est
pas là pour faire un procès mais on est
dans un moment difficile et je pense que
le gouvernement devrait cesser de penser
qu'il est le seul à avoir les réponses
et peut-être qu'il peut écouter ce que
disent aussi les oppositions parce que
notre démarche elle se veut constructive
il ya plusieurs semaines déjà de sacs
nous disions il faut réquisitionner les
entreprises de production de matériel
parce que on va être dans une pénurie
il faut faire en sorte de nationaliser
une entreprise comme luxe faire qu est
la dernière entreprise de production en
france
des bouteilles d'oxygène qui sont
nécessaires dans les respirateurs voilà
nous on est là dans une démarche d une
démarche de propositions ce qui ne
serait pas responsable c'est de ne pas
écouter vous savez la démocratie c'est
pas un poids y compris dans les moments
de crise au contraire parce que ça
permet d'écouter des points de vue qui
sont pas toujours les mêmes qui peuvent
être contradictoires des critiques et
ses critiques elle vise à améliorer la
manière avec laquelle la crise est gérée
aujourd'hui on n'a pas l'impression
d'assister à une gestion de crise mais à
une gestion de pénurie vous savez la
france est soumise à la lancer une
commission d' enquête citoyenne et tout
à l'heure j'ai changé avec
ça un syndicaliste dédouaner il me
disait mais jusqu'au 15 mars on n'a pas
vu une seule trace d'une commande par
l'état français de masques et pourtant
les douaniers ils voient toutes les
commandes passées et donc cette gestion
là qui est en retard
il me semble je pense que c'est
nécessaire qui est des voix qui puisse
dire attention là il ya un problème pour
qu'ensuite ça puisse être corrigé merci
emmanuel bompard d'avoir répondu à la
question je rappelle que vous êtes
eurodéputés chef de la délégation de la
france soumise au parlement européen et
figure de votre parti dans la région de
toulouse où se trouvent les usines
airbus